B
[Silence]
Al
for
[Silence]
dear brothers and
sisters
welcome in our
mid Muslim Community Center of
tan I'm very happy today because you are
here and everyone
here Muslim and
Christian
because I believe and
everyone here believe
also the Islam and Christian and
Jews they
will outside from one
way
because we believe we have one
God this God who
created all this
universe and also who
believe of all prophecy and
Messengers
started from Prophet
no peace be upon him and
Abraham and mes and Joseph and David
andan and
Jacob
and Jes says peace be upon him and to
Muhammad peace be upon all of
them and all prophets and
Messengers they invite the
mankind to believe to Allah is
one this is very
important and give and
give all our worship only to
God the
almighty
today we will speak
about the
Miracles of Quran the Holy
Quran for this I will speak Arabic
language brother
imar he will translate for
you
[Silence]
in the name of God the most merciful the
beneficent I greet you all all with the
greetings of
Peace the sh started by saying that all
the Messengers of God who were sent they
all came with a certain miracle for the
[Silence]
people
be
there are two categories of the
Miracles prophets they are the ones who
receive the
highest kind of miracle that God through
them
performs that's called MOA in Islamic
terms MOA and that belongs only for the
prophets and then the she mentioned the
other category it is called k k also is
a the type of Miracle however is not as
the miracle of the
prophets it
is a different Miracle which is in a
lower
level however it is performed by God
through these Saints or righteous people
that God chooses so not anymore prophets
because prophets they belong to a higher
state but we're talking about other
righteous people Saints
who are close to God and he enables them
to perform these
Miracles so every so people they can
[Silence]
Witness
m
in order to let the other speakers
behind me talk I'm going to wrap it up
quick and I'm going to talk about the
miracle that God sent down to Prophet
Moses and this miracle was sent down to
him in order to Prevail over the other
Miracle well over the other Magics
that were being displayed back in that
time so at the time of Moses there were
many
people who perform magic and in order
for this
magic to be downgraded and the
miracle of God to be
superior God had to send Moses with a
miracle that was going to supersede all
of these other M Magics and that's where
he received the stick and with that
stick he was able to show it in front of
the people and that became a a snake
that was
[Silence]
alive
subh
and also at the time of Jesus peace and
blessings of God be upon
him at that time it was
very popular and very well spread the
practice of
medicine so you had so many doctors who
were able to cure different kind of
diseases therefore it was necessary for
God to send down a
messenger a prophet who was going to
supersede with this mirle of God all of
those all of that Evolution that was
taking place back in those days so he
gave him a
special special Miracles with him he
equipped him with special Miracles so he
can be above all of the achievement of
that century
[Silence]
and also at his time another
miracle was at the time of Jesus peace
be upon him the sending down of the
table full of food the supper that the
Christians refer to where you have the
apostles sitting down with him that
was another major miracle that was
performed right in front of
them
ay
[Silence]
for
I'm going to read in English this
verse from there is a Surah in the Quran
there is a chapter in the Quran revealed
specifically only for this supper only
for this occasion when the table came
down full of food and
fruits verse number
110 from Al in the Arabic language which
translates to when God will say oh Jesus
Son of Mary remember my favor on you and
on your mother when I strengthened you
with the Holy Spirit you spoke to the
people in the
cradle
and when an old age and and when you
were in an old age when also when I Tau
when I went of old age and when I taught
you the book and the wisdom and the taat
which is the Bible the the Old Testament
and the New Testament in and when you
determined out of clay a think the
form of a bird by my
permission then you breathed into it and
it became a bird by my
permission and you healed the blinds and
the LEP by my
permission and when you brought forth
the dead by my
permission and when I withheld the
children of Israel from you when you
came to them with clear
arguments but those who disbelieve among
them said this is nothing but clear
enchantment
[Silence]
for
and also when we go back to the Arabic
term of the word Messiah that comes even
in English from the Arabic or the
Aramaic word which is
Messi Messiah Messi
it means the one who
wipes the one who wipes because in
reality he used to wipe those people on
their eyes their faces when they were
blind so God can return back the
eyesight to them the one who
wipes and also he also wiped when he
resurrected when he gave life back to
the dead he also wiped
that dead person and God insert life
back to that body to that dead body so
it is a
beautiful connection
between his between his his
real message and his name between his
real actions as a prophet as a me
messenger of God and his true name
there's a true Connection in
between
and he was told that the time
ended give me few
brother as for the miracle of our
blessed Prophet Muhammad
his Miracle is the
[Silence]
Quran
now when we talk about the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
he was a man who was
illiterate he did not know how to read
and right and most of the people when
they are in that state of being
illiterate they would feel a sense of
shyness and
also kind of uncomfortable in front of
the
people because the others would know how
to read and write but these people would
not so there is stepping back a little
bit but when it comes to the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him it was the
opposite because even though he was an
illiterate he did not know how to read
and write but because of what he was
receiving was superseding everything
else at that
[Silence]
time
so at that time when Prophet appeared in
in in this Society this Society
you have to understand that it was a
society who
was who had a lot of
Professionals
in
putting the words together being able to
have a beautiful speech they would wrap
up big sentences long sentences maybe in
two three words they had these gifts
that other nations they did not have so
they were qualified they have these
specialities in beautiful speech in
or
oratory and they were compared to the
other people they were so different so
Prophet came during this time when this
was going on in that
[Silence]
Society
foran
[Silence]
Allah
subhah
beside the fact that Quran was revealed
to Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
of God be upon him
to speak to the
people in a way of rhyme it's it's in a
poetic way beside that the Quran also
had so many miracles
included that tonight the speakers are
going to talk about these Miracles they
come
during a time when nobody would even
expect to know these details for example
the details about the rotation of the
sun people thought before that the sun
was always stable does not rotate does
not move or anything that until
lately but now the scientist discovered
that the Sun Also does a certain
rotation and these are all facts that
are mentioned in the Quran
therefore it's not only a book that was
revealed to the people back in those
days to defeat or to challenge their
beautiful way of speaking but also it
came as a book full of Miracles
convincing the people back in those days
and continue to convince the people
nowadays because and it will continue in
the future to convince people and to
challenge people also and to make people
believe in this book because simply it
is the book of the almighty God revealed
to his
messenger thank you so
much this topic is very very long I
can't with the 15 or
inah thank you siram alikum just want
to interrupt a minute here we got pizza
that's going to get cold so here's what
we're going to do in the interest of
time we're going to pass the pizza us
around with the small plates so grab
what you want and then continue let's
continue with the process please forgive
us a little bit of a you know timing or
constraint here but we want to leave
some time for the question and answer
session at the back end so that's why I
think we want to just move it along is
that
okay can we go ahead and just pass the P
way
oh